I am a walking failure story so I got a
great question a sad question from one
of my followers Monica love you guys
who wrote in to say hi I'm literally a
walking talking complete opposite of you
failure story I tried to turn things
around many times but it's difficult
when the build-up is so big and the
mistakes just make things sink so much
deeper I just turned 30 not too long ago
I'm at the point where I'm just ready to
give up on success I wish I didn't say
that because really I don't want to give
up but I'm at the age now when people
are like well what happened you aren't
in your 20s anymore so why are you here
my passion is an illustration art design
the last thing I'm going to try is sort
of my swan song which is an attempt to
illustrate my own stories but this in
itself is by far the riskiest and least
likely for success of all the things
I've tried is there a way to build
something out of nothing I know I won't
get support from my friends or family
everyone thinks it's ridiculous that I
failed so badly up until this point so
no one wants to talk to me is it even
possible to make something happen by
myself is it possible to start this last
risky venture and make it work thanks
for your awesome videos and website
Monica Monica is a great question and I
really feel for you I feel I feel sad
reading your message and I want to know
that you're not alone almost every
single entrepreneur has gone through or
is going through what you're going
through now and the most successful ones
if you look back on their career they
failed they failed they failed they
failed they failed their way to success
I was a guy making $300 a month feeling
like I had no self-worth trying to cling
on any bit of dignity and value that I
could telling my partner that I quit
feeling like a total failure
and it's why running the business one of
the hardest things you ever gonna do in
your life chasing your dreams is not
easy that's why most people don't don't
get there I want you to first know that
you're not alone that everybody is going
through this is tons of people going
through this right now and and that if
you are really committed to your dream
you have to continue on and and I have
three bits of advice for you that
hopefully will help you get to a place
of happiness
from where you are now even as I'm
talking I'm I've lost energy and I'm
feeling sad so I want you to climb out
of this hole
the very first thing that you need to do
is change your beliefs you know you you
have a belief system right now of
failure all you've known is failure your
environment supports failure right your
friends your family they don't support
you everybody thinks you're ridiculous
you know you're surrounded by so much
failure it's not about such a negative
environment that if you go out and try
to launch this new business with all you
have is failure on your mind you're
gonna fail it's going to continue to
fail everything we touch will keep
failing because all you surrounded
yourself with is failure and a negative
attitude and and I get that that's where
you've come from because you have this
you have a whole bunch of stuff around
you that keeps bringing you down where
you need to start changing that belief
system and the two things I suggest the
first one is surround yourself with
stories that build you up I would look
at entrepreneurs who have done what you
want to do is you want to be an art and
illustration design look at Walt Disney
look at Calvin Klein look at Pablo
Picasso look at look at artists that you
look up to and respect and look at their
stories of how they got started right
how they went from their idea to making
their first you know big win how did
they get through that because chances
are was through a lot of failure I loved
Walt Disney is one of my favorite
entrepreneurs of all time and I know his
story and you know that story still
inspires me when when he was getting
started his first company was selling
laugh-o-grams in that company what went
bankrupt
you know I failed and he was so poor
that he had to live out of his office he
couldn't afford rent and he finally had
a big hit with Oswald the Lucky Rabbit
and then his distributor stole it from
him and left him with nothing I had to
start all over again and he kept going
now let the Mickey Mouse and that led to
a huge creation for him but he failed
and failed and failed and failed and
risked everything and people thought he
was crazy and and he eventually made it
and that's the story of a lot of
successful entrepreneurs and so what I
found was
by reading those success stories it made
me feel a little less crazy right it
made me feel more like hey maybe I could
do this too you know that that guy while
Disney is not not so different than me
Bill Gates is not so different than me
and their stories of early failure
inspired me to want to keep going and
and start to change the belief system
that I had because of my family I don't
have successful entrepreneurs you know
people in my family were government
workers and in politics and you know
career people and so I couldn't look up
to anybody say I'm gonna I'm gonna be
like you now they didn't bash me then
say we don't support your dream they're
really supportive but but I didn't have
role models to look up to and so those
stories that I read those famous
entrepreneurs started changing my belief
system and made me believe in myself
that hey these guys can do it so I can
do it too so I looked at who your
favorite famous entrepreneurs are
finding their stories and start to get
inspired the next thing I'll do is start
to hang out in your industry you see you
like Art and Design and start to hang
out with those people right if your
friends and your family don't get it
they think you're ridiculous stop
hanging around them and start hanging
out with the people who do get it who
love it who you know I want you to start
feeling some hope again I want you to
start feeling inspired I want you to
come alive again you know it sounds like
you haven't had that in your life for a
long time and and when you are
surrounded by people who share a same
vision as you who are excited with you
they give you energy and momentum and
connections and ideas and they build you
up and that's what you need you know I
just started as an example a new venture
in the League of Legends world that's a
video game and you know nobody in my
family plays computer games and they
don't understand what it's all about and
my friends don't really get it either
but that's okay I'm not hanging out with
them you know I'm not trying to convince
them that this is a good idea
instead I'm sending my energy hanging
out in the in those circles right I'm
going to events and go into screenings
and hanging out with the players and and
the artists and the people who are
involved in that community and making
connections and getting coach
building up a YouTube channel you know
and so hanging around people who get it
build it up for me give me energy
they're teaching me stuff right we're
feeding off of each other it's way
better than we just try to create it in
isolation and just being pounded on
people who are saying that this is a
stupid ideas and we're going to work so
one start reading those stories and then
to start hanging around in your industry
to get excited and fall in love and get
some hope back ok that's how you change
your belief system at the start the
second bit of advice I have is get a
mentor you know I'm honestly scared for
you to see this last venture as your
swan song you know put everything into
it if that doesn't work then then what
do you do right I don't know I'm
honestly a little bit scared for you and
so I would say don't start this now
because you're not ready instead go and
get a mentor and find someone who's in
your industry who you look up to and say
I want to be like that person you know I
could see myself being that person and
they can give you the guidance to help
you not make mistakes to help you learn
the ropes to help you make industry
contacts and you know the first mentor
that I had I had nobody growing up okay
I had I had nobody to talk to about my
business besides my business partners
and and we felt lost and confused and
failing and struggling in the first the
first mentor I found was that just to my
bank right like I had I had so little
contacts the only person I could think
of was to go to my my bank I didn't even
know anybody there I just made an
appointment and went in and said hi I'd
like to talk to you about how I can grow
my business I don't need a loan I don't
need money
but I don't know what to do to grow my
company and and they took pity on me or
they liked my story and they introduced
me to somebody and
you know that person couldn't help me
but he introduced me to somebody who
introduced me to somebody and that last
person became my first mentor in
business his name was John and that was
going from a place of total despair
total unhappiness total lack of of
connection and resources and just doing
something about it and talking to the
only place I could think of the bank and
it led me eventually not hung at it I
hung out you know the first one didn't
work next one didn't work the third guy
did and that was John and he showed me
the ropes and he gave me advice and
wisdom and and I don't know if my
business would have done well without
him I may have quit and so I want the
same thing for you I want somebody to
help guide you along your path somebody
who doesn't think you're crazy someone
who recognizes your art and your talent
and your creativity and can see the
future direction for where you can go
you know someone who can who can teach
you things that would take you forever
to learn on your own and then you
definitely never learn from your friends
or family and that comes from hanging
out in the industry and certainly get to
know people and letting people see your
passion vision and starting to make some
connections you know and that comes from
you getting out there so you got to do
that get that mentor before you launch
your business and number three is start
part time you don't need to jump all in
you don't need to you don't need to you
know put every last dime you have into
this idea start working for somebody
part time start working for some really
full time and start your business on the
side you know get to figure out is that
the industry you want to get into if you
want to make your own book by
illustrating designs go work for
somebody who's doing exactly that right
who's making illustrations for books and
see if you like it see if you enjoy see
if that makes you come alive see if you
start to have a hope and excitement and
meaning again in your life and if that's
it then you can continue on and start
your business on the part-time side you
know evenings weekends whatever it is
and if that's not it then then you've
learned and you've gotten paid to learn
and go find something else that that you
feel excited and passionate about and
you may bounce from one job to another
to another
but hopefully each time it gets you
closer to a path that feels right and I
would encourage you throughout this
whole thing is to follow your flow and
follow what what excites you and follow
again what makes you come alive because
that's going to really make the
difference to build you out of this deep
hole that you dug yourself into I hope
that helps I really feel for you you
know I want you to to be successful and
I want you to realize your talents and I
know what it's like to be beaten up by
the little man and I'd like to see your
art you know and for those who are
watching if you have suggestions if you
want to share your story you want to you
want to give some advice and feedback
please leave in the comments below I'm
sure Monica will be watching in Monica I
love to see an example of your art to
share a link so everybody can see all
the great work that you're up to and
where your talent lies and hopefully by
having a little bit of momentum from the
the believed nation community that'll
inspire you to keep going in and
following your dreams you guys like this
video subscribe to the channel thank you
so much for watching I'll see you soon
every week I share inspiring and
motivational stories that really mean
something to me
that I hope you'll check out in my
newsletter below
you